walker bueller faces the padres again
4-0 lifetime against him with a 1-6-2
era
only zach greinke with a better career
era against the padres in a dodger
uniform
that includes his outing on friday game
one when these teams met up in san diego
gave up two runs over six innings
it was dominant with the cutter and when
you talk about walker bueller
he doesn't like to be embarrassed in
front of people glad to have
fans back in dodger stadium fernando
tatis junior from walker bueller and he
starts the night with a strikeout at 97.
very confident fastballs from walker
bueller
trent grisham coming up swinging and a
miss
an angry fastball at 97 and back-to-back
haze to open tonight
a chance to strike out the side instead
of bouncer up the middle at second base
tonight sheldon noisy making his dodgers
stadium debut completes a one two three
first inning for walker bueller 21 year
old making his second start
he is familiar with these dodgers last
time out three and two thirds
pitched well gave up a hit struck out
three and here's
justin turner turner will have this one
picked by machado the throw to second is
in time that shoulder's been bothering
him and he stretched it out pretty good
down there to make that play
at the lead runner in bets spectacular
play
by the padres third baseman from his
knees
getting the lead runner bets at second
base
one out in the top of the second inning
there's a high fly ball to left center
field
well hit back at the wall pollock makes
the catch
against the wall pollock had it well
tracked
every step of the way well kind of a
cool night you better get all of it and
for myers you go back to the dugout and
you'll get a hang with them and
no classic case had just missed it now
here's
weathers who throws left and bats right
cued off the end of the bat
along the line bueller throws and gets
him they took a good long look at it and
said that's not rolling foul
is it so he had to grab it and throw him
out nine up nine down for bueller no
score after two and a half
no hits yet walker bueller and ryan
weathers doing what they did on friday
night
bueller slashes the first hit of the
night into right field
so much for that lack of stress got to
bear down against everybody with this
dodger club
starting pitchers normally able to
competition amongst themselves
and for bueller he uh there's a board to
be some agitation marks tomorrow during
early batting practice when the dodgers
are home these starting pitchers will
take goofy
andres will be coming to bat here
looking for their first base run of the
night
against walker bueller who is nine up
nine down to start
and he'll hit a line drive into left
field for a base head
over is pollock and a wide turn at first
but back to the bag at first is tatis
jumping on that first pitch and there's
the first padres hit of the night i'll
take that
and tatis is aboard with grisham coming
up tatis
[Applause]
seeger but hits the umpire and stays in
the infield
and that's the only to stop it from
going into the the bleachers or into
this
center field not a good throw and
nobody was going to get in front of that
ball to block it no right off the boiler
wow
glad to see chad is okay first man in
scoring position for either team tonight
and machado comes up
and a liner into left field for a base
hit tatis being waved around
pollock's throw is not going to go to
the plate and scoring
from second is fernando tatis and the
padres strike first
on top one to nothing manny machado
driving in the game's first run
another lenia for manny machado a
curveball
really outer third manny machado laces
this ball
again beating it right through the shift
fernando tatis junior was on his horse
they had no shot to get him padres one
nothing lead
and ryan withers has really been walking
on a little bit of a tight road so far
tonight guys he's allowed to lead off
batter to reach base in all three
innings
will smith the cleanup hitter that is on
the inside corner and it's straight
three
five strikeouts for ryan weathers and
two outs here at the bottom of the
fourth inning padres
in front one to nothing two two swing
and a miss six strikeouts for ryan
weathers in a one two three fourth
inning
he is shutting out the dodgers it was
zach mckinstry the singlet against him
on friday night it's walker bueller that
has the only hit tonight
rolls it up the first baseline going to
be a very tough play for weathers
who throws it past the first base yeah
they're going to call him out because
really was running inside
that 45-foot line he was actually in
fair territory
he's just now discovering he has been
called out he was called out by home
plate umpire tony randazzo who signaled
yes
he was inside the line you have to run
between those two lines the last 45 feet
down the line
two outs bases empty is a slow ground
ball left of the mound weathers again
picks it up with a glove fire to first
he got him what a play by ryan weathers
getting it done on the mound and off big
time defense being played by the kid
from loretto andres
one run three hits bueller has struck
out seven hasn't walked anybody
two strikeouts tonight for grisham one
of the first one in the fourth
both swinging there's a drive to right
field off the bat at trent grisham
his fourth home run deep into the
pavilion at dodger stadium
puts a padres on top two to nothing this
pitch goes
in at 94 and it leaves at about 107.
we've talked about the high fastball all
night yeah
oh yeah that was a high fastball and you
know what don it that that's a poke at
dodger stadium
three quarters of the way up the
pavilion that is a poke
and the padres have doubled their lead
two to nothing here in the sixth
my lord talking about getting on some
high
cheese pine weather is already the
longest outing of his career one out in
the bottom of the sixth inning this
is caught laying it out is jake connor
were to make the grab on the backhand
two down rob sieger of a base hit
defense has to be sound and it has
certainly been that way as ryan weathers
will exit
a terrific start for him tonight ryan
does not allow a run
and one hit a single to the opposing
pitcher
what a night for weather what's going to
take for this offense to get going buddy
it's very quiet and it's very rare that
this is going to happen with these
resumes
a fly ball to left field and pollock has
just left the yard the dodgers are not
going to be shut out tonight
they will go 91 straight without having
been shut out
for pollock his first home run of the
year and the dodgers are back to within
two to one
so they break through on aj pollock's
first home run of this season it's a 2-1
game
now it's a one-run game as sheldon noisy
steps in
it's a towering drive left center field
it is gone
dodgers go back-to-back hulk and noisy
the game is tied at two sheldon
noisy's first home run as a dodger
evens the score padres tonight one for
three with runners in scoring position
first pitch from china swung on again
ground ball to short backhand seeger to
second for one
on to first is in time double play the
run scores though
and the padres have taken a three to two
lead here in the eighth and a chance to
make dodger stadium rock
again bases loaded in a one-run game in
the eighth
and this is the second heats up
chronoworth the second for one
on to first they got him nicely done
cronoworth gets that baseball in a tough
hop
flips to second for one on to first the
dp ends the inning
some kind of play by the padres this is
one of the best double plays
if turn that you'll probably see in a
long time
so a couple k's to open the ninth for
melanson against eight nine in the order
and it's up to mookie betts
strikes out the padres win a 3-2 padres
win
what a night in l.a for the san diego
padres